now support for Ukraine and migration
policies are expected to top the agenda
at a two-day meeting of EU leaders in
Brussels NATO Secretary General will
attend and he's already promised support
to Ukraine
immediate and Urgent task is to support
Ukraine to ensure that Ukraine prevails
as a sovereign independent nation in
Europe because unless we are able to do
that there is no membership issue to be
discussed at all and let me also mention
that this is also where uh where an area
where we see a link with the European
Union because of course the the EU
decision to Grant uh Ukraine candidate
status of course also has an impact on
the discussions which are taking place
within NATO together with European Union
NATO allies have provided unprecedented
support and and we are stepping up just
over the last weeks we have seen a new
announcements from EU but also from NATO
allies or additional support and also
the training of the F-16 parties have
started
well we have acid bags standing by for a
SIM key but first let's cross over to
Dominic Kane he joins us now from
Brussels and uh Dominic obviously a very
lengthy agenda of what has to be
discussed but what are we expecting to
come out of this Summit
yeah the first thing to say is that
there are as you say many different
elements on this agenda on the agenda
here at this Summit particularly the
situation in Ukraine but there are many
others insofar as the situation in
Ukraine is concerned we've heard from
Jen Steinberg Secretary General of NASA
standing next to the president of the
European Council Michelle effectively
saying variations on the theme that the
two institutions have said since the
start of what Mr Putin would call that
special military operation the war in
Ukraine as the rest of the world might
see it unanimity of purpose about
Ukraine and the financial aid that's
been profit to Ukraine insofar as the
EPF is concerned that is the European
peace facility which was mentioned by EU
foreign ministers earlier this week but
if there is unanimity or Unity of
purpose on Ukraine there does not appear
to be such Unity insofar as migration is
concerned and that is another key theme
at this Summit certainly there are two
sides to the equation viewers might
recall that three weeks ago in
Luxembourg EU interior ministers
appeared to agree a deal via quality
excuse me by qualified majority voting
21 Nations action 27 voting for a deal
on migration six that did not vote for
it well today we know that the Polish
ministers have said that they want a
different plan that they don't agree
with the ideas that were put forward in
Luxembourg Mr moravitsky has said that
he has something else in mind and has
proposed something else which would not
require this qualified majority voting
which should be unanimously agreed on
the other hand you have people such are
as Mrs Maloney from Italy the Italian
Prime Minister effectively saying the
deal that was signed is very good not
just for Italy but for the EU so you
have a certain element of fault line
there and then other nations to opining
as it were all have shots the German
Chancellor saying it's a good deal it's
a deal that the EU has thrashed at
people should stick to it so clearly
Ukraine very important but also
migration is a key theme Here wk4sm
Brussels thanks to the update Dominic
Let's cross over to Ukraine's Capital
key right as the beggar standing by and
I said of course Ukraine uh will be
watching very closely because they want
to see what comes out of this meeting
because they have a wish list as well
don't they
yes they do and their wish list has
remained the same throughout they want
NATO membership they want uh more
weapons and they want more money now in
terms of the NATO membership presence
Leslie has said over the last few days
that the country should disregard the
Kremlin and they should not be looking
over their shoulder after what he called
was a leader that is incapable obviously
referring to president uh Putin of
Russia but it's been very clear that
NATO will not intervene directly in this
conflict in Ukraine and that Ukraine
cannot join NATO before the war is over
now the EU EU MEPS voted earlier this
month on a resolution uh calling on NATO
to uphold or honor their agreement with
Ukraine to join NATO but obviously
saying that that can only happen once
the war is over now Germany and the
United States have been very very of
doing anything that will take them into
active conflict with Russia Russia has
always said that NATO's expansion on
Eastern Europe is evidence of hostility
but in terms of money Ukraine has
received considerable fronts from around
the world especially the EU even this
year's budget Ukraine's National budget
nine billion euros of that was from the
EU and the EU commission met earlier
this month and they were proposing a
special measure of around 50 billion
dollars to help Ukraine from 2024 to
2027 but the big question Still Remains
everything hinges on when this war will
end and right now nobody knows we are
hearing from the ukrainians that they
are making advances although they are
very minimal the front lines still
remain the same there hasn't really been
a breakthrough but a lot of what Ukraine
wants in terms of that NATO membership
depends on when this ends but they're
always looking for more weapons and more
money thanks so much
leave well